here at home the first female governor
of new york is calling for a dramatic
culture shift in politics after her
predecessor andrew cuomo left office in
disgrace kathy hokel was sworn in
yesterday following cuomo's resignation
amid allegations of sexual harassment
which he denies and an impeachment probe
by state lawmakers hokal had been the
state's lieutenant governor yesterday
she pledged to focus on ethical
governing and said her top priorities
include fighting the delta variant and
requiring masks in school she joins us
now governor good morning welcome
good morning thanks for having me on the
show when you say
you're committed to changing the culture
in albany new york state capitol how do
you intend to do that
well first of all i've ordered that
every single state employee has to do an
in-person sexual harassment and ethics
training that is not the case now
everyone's familiar with the dynamic
where there's requirements you have
training and everyone clicks through on
their computer and says they've done it
that's not happening i want to make sure
that people have no excuses that they
understand what our policies are but
also i'm going to lead by example i'm
going to personally make sure that every
young woman woman of all ages who work
in this in this environment as well as
members of the lgbtq community who often
feel they've been preyed upon by others
i want everyone to know that my
administration is going to be open
transparent and an environment where
people can just do their jobs without
fear of harassment and anyone who
crosses the line they're going to have
to deal with me there's no tolerance for
anyone who abuses their positions and
that's the message i'm sending but i'm
not just going to talk the talk i'm
going to make sure we walk the walk so
at the end of my terms that people
understand there's been a huge change in
culture and it's starting day one you've
also said you're going to make covet
obviously a top priority and you said
new yorkers can expect new vaccine
requirements
what are you planning
well first of all parents are very
stressed out about school right around
the corner i'm a mom i can understand
the stress levels are off the charts so
we have to first of all have mandatory
mask which is something that's not
universally popular but i think it's
important step toward getting safety in
schools we've also announced a very
aggressive testing program available to
students and teachers 800 i'm sorry 585
million dollars dedicated to that as
well as a partnership with writing when
it comes to vaccinations the what i
mentioned before i have authority to do
as governor i don't have the executive
power to mandate vaccinations in schools
but i'll be working closely to come to
that conclusion by by teaming up with
our our partners in the education
community and our school superintendents
and school boards this has to happen
because this has gone on too long our
children need to be back in school they
need to be back in that normal learning
environment because we've lost too much
time particularly for children in black
and brown communities those who come
from impoverished neighborhoods they
already start out with strikes against
them and we cannot let this continue we
need them back in school you certainly
are setting a new tone governor hoakland
congratulations to you in the governor's
office but there seemed to have been a
tsunami of reports of negativity about
the toxicity in the governor's office
you worked with andrew cuomo for several
years were you just not aware of what
was happening in his office
well i had the title as lieutenant
governor that did not mean we work side
by side in fact i determined early on
that the governor had his own way and i
have my way it's no secret that we're
not close for the last seven years we
actually run separately for governor
lieutenant governor in the primary so
that all being said everyone knew that
but what i've done as lieutenant
governor is take the messages and
learning from what other people are
doing all around the state i've been all
62 counties
every year so i spend very little time
in the rooms where
this whole culture was festering so
but i know that there's a lot of good
people who want to stay in government i
want to create a different environment
and let them know it's a whole new day
here in albany